Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're gonna take a look
at the World Partition tool that we have for Unreal.
Now, again, this is gonna be a bit of an overview
and not a full deep dive
as we do have classes covering this in more detail.
So let's get started.
So how it works.
So we're gonna be opening up
the World Partition EXE project.
I'm giving you two projects
in this particular group of classes.
One of them was in the world that we were building
and then this one takes a bit of our mini dark ruins
and puts it into a world with a World Partition set up.
So the World Partition divides your world to a grid
and you can adjust the settings to that grid
to when and how they load.
And you can think of it as virtual texturing
but this is virtual level building
so that the most important parts of your world
are loading where your player is at
and that's kind of what you can do
and you can manage that controlling your cell side
to load the level in smaller sections
for interactive flow and customization.
So it's really great.
It's easier to make larger worlds with it
as it handles the data,
keeping things compartmentalized and loaded
as needed with the grid system.
So this grid system is very beneficial
and makes it so you can control via sections
and how things are to be loaded.
It's pretty awesome.
So how it works also is the open world default map type
is designed to be a starting point
for creating large open world maps
and comes with the following features enabled by default.
You have World Partition,
you have the one file per actor
to streamline saving assets
so there's no waiting for checking with version control
and you also have data layers
and you can dynamically load and unload layers
in the editor to help manage complex worlds.
So not only are you working with World Partition,
you can have data layers
as well as hierarchical levels of detail.
Kind of what we've talked about HLODs before
but these are HLODs specifically catered
to the world building World Partition tool.
It's used to control the calculation of assets
so you can bundle assets for quicker calculations.
All of these are set up to help streamlining production
for larger worlds.
So let's go and see how that works
and we're going to punch in a couple of CVars
to see that in real time.
So you can see right now we're in the world
and we're looking around
in the environment that I've given you.
You want to make sure when you do start out
or grab any kind of level,
double check to make sure you have enabled streaming.
This is really important
if you're grabbing a set of levels from the marketplace
and you want to use World Partition,
enable streaming is going to be very important.
You'll notice there's a runtime hash class
that we can choose.
The default that I have on this particular map
that I've given you has the hash set
but the newer one or the newer set of data calculation
that we have is a World Partition runtime spatial hash.
So I do recommend using that one when possible.
For purposes of just us working in class
I'm going to leave it as hash set
but again this one is a little bit more streamlined
and a little bit more up to date and is a better value
because it is a latest and greatest
but it's really up to you
and both do work great
but this one is the newest kid on the block.
So another thing we can do to see how this looks like
in our scene, there are a couple of ways to view
what is being calculated.
One of them in the outliner, I can go in here
and let me delete what I have and do the up arrow.
You'll see that we have as in my documentation says
a WTP runtime toggle draw runtime hash 2D
and when I enter this, hit enter
and I hit play in my scene
you're going to see the calculations active
in my environment and you'll see that each grid
in sections being loaded as I move around
and you'll see that almost like a radar system
in the very middle that we have our focal area
basically where that line is showing my directional point
on the very end of that is where I am in the world
and I mean the end is in towards the middle
and you can see where I'm looking
where I am viewing the data areas in the scene.
As you can see the hand moving as I turn my head around.
I'm going to hit escape
and we're going to go and turn that off for now.
So let's go back in that line or output.
I mean the up arrow, I'm going to select that again
and I'm just going to hit enter
and I've turned it off now.
We can also preview this in real time.
So if I want to go in my editor
so if I want to preview
I can show grid preview here in my main layer
and I can turn that on
and I can do that for each one if I wanted to.
So now when I move around in the world
you're going to see the grid draw and build
as I circumvent or move around in this environment.
Let's go and move up in the world there.
We're going to pass through the wall.
We're going to go back to the beach area.
There we go.
Passing through all the rock
and we'll find ourselves back on the beach.
And you can see our grid region that we're calculating.
Now notice this one isn't very big
but you can again can see how this works.
I'm going to hit escape out of here
or actually I should turn this off.
We're not really in play mode.
I'll just grab a piece of geometry, hit the F key
and we can be a little bit closer to where we were before.
Again, we are in full control
of how the data is being digested.
Again, underneath windows, you will see console variables
or we can control and run some of those that we just ran
but we also have world partition here
and we can look at the content puddles
as well as the data layers.
So if I click on the data layer outliner
you'll see that we have these in place
and at any time I can turn them off if I need to
but it helps with really quick management
of my environment.
You can see as I click on them
I can get the details of what I need
to be able to open this up
and make sure that everything's running accordingly
in my scene.
Now, when we look at our world details here
let's go to our world settings.
You'll notice as I scroll down a bit
that we are using HLODs for our environment.
Here's a default HLOD layer.
Now it's up to you if you build these
how you want to load them
and exactly how you want to manage everything
but it's pretty simple to be able to do so
as you can right click again
and choose data layer or HLOD
to be able to compartmentalize the data as needed.
If we go back to our slides
you'll see that how this works
is it reduces complexity and provides a scalable solution
when creating new projects.
RID cell streaming can be enabled
and disabled using the enable streaming option
in the world settings.
The following templates use a world partition
but have enabled streaming disabled by default.
So you can turn that on if you need to.
So when editing your world
actors can be added anywhere
and are automatically assigned to a grid cell
based on their spatially loaded setting
found in their detail panels
of the world partition section.
So you can manage all of this as you need
and you can adjust things.
Now, again, it's worthy.
You have to test this out.
Because you need to decide once you get your layout
once you know exactly what your player is going to be
you can determine how the cells are being digested
where you need to put them
and where the concentration of
as you working through your scene
where you need to optimize things
and where things need to run smoother
and where these tools can help you manage that
when necessary.
Well, that's it with this one.
Here's some more links to give you some detail
and deeper dives into these topics.
And don't forget,
we have a class that dives into this pretty deep
and it will definitely help you out
if you decide to take this route for your game.
Thanks again.